the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski has arrived in Berlin today he
was welcomed with military honors by
Chancellor Olaf Schultz Mr zielenski is
there chiefly to talk about more arms
and ammunition deliveries let's speak to
our Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins
who joins me now from Berlin so Italy
yesterday Siobhan
Germany today mainly to talk about arms
and ammo
important trick for two reasons one for
shoring up alliances but secondly
because it gave us an important glimpse
into how Ukraine seized the progress of
the war so president zielinski arrived
here in Berlin he met the president and
then he met the chancellor Olaf Schultz
and was treated to full military honors
outside the Chancery here in Berlin and
then he lauded Germany for what he said
was a true friend and reliable Ally now
that's an interesting note from
president zielinski because over the
last year there have been moments where
Germany has frustrated Ukraine in its
perceived slowness for example in
releasing weapons so you'll remember
back in January there was that too and
fro about whether Germany would release
the leopard two tanks it eventually did
but after a huge amount of pressure and
so it was interesting that on his first
trip to Germany since the war broke out
that president zielinski was Keen to
underline that they are firm friends and
he also said that German intervention
and support for Ukraine during the war
had saved Ukrainian life something he
said Kiev Keith would be forever
grateful for now Olaf Schultz returned
the warm words and also said that they
would continue to support Ukraine for as
long as it takes and also continue to
send Aid to Ukraine going into the
future but in terms of looking ahead to
where this war is going president
zelenski first of all talked about the
counter-offensive that's being planned
he said there was no intention of this
deliberately targeting Russian territory
instead he claimed that the focus of the
counter-offensive would be to get back a
area that had been occupied by Russia in
the Ukraine he also said that he
believed that Russia's defeat could be
irreversible by possibly the end of this
year with support of our lives but he
said while he was open to discussing
peace with outside parties it had to be
on Ukraine's terms it couldn't be other
people dictating to them and on that
point Olaf Schultz was quite supportive
he said that he would support Ukraine
with these peace negotiations but that
Russia for example couldn't say well
this is what we want and you have to do
it that Russia would have to remove
their troops but as I was saying this is
an important visit because of the
tensions which we've seen at times in
the past year between Germany and
Ukraine and the fact that Germany is now
one of its biggest military and
financial supporters and this was really
a moment for the Ukrainian president to
say thank you and also to shore up
political and public support going
forward
Siobhan thank you